this thing's the technical difficulties
with one citation needed join me today
he read books you know it's Chris Joel I
am Kermit the Frog and tonight Matthew I
am going to be that little flat guy from
Frogger I would say gala grand gala
granites covered in resin and brimming
with juicy seeds oh and the bounty smell
means that my grade hello YouTube Studio
One ha ha in front of me I have an
article from Wikipedia and these folks
can't see it every fact we got right to
the point and a ding pick on the ding no
I put on the decorative and there's a
special prize for particular dancers
which is oh yeah I just conducted that
in Walt's dad today we are talking about
Benjamin Rush huh is that what happens
when the shop of Benjamin's opened on
Black Friday Benjamin Rush yes if this
rating is it streets fine
for a drug I'll go get my Benjamin
Russian people around licking wax
mannequins have Ben Franklin soos wham
bam from Madame Tussauds no Maggie Oh
Maggie you are surprisingly close with
Benjamin Franklin that was he a friend
of his I'll give you point he was a
founding father of the United States
okay that shows prehistory on my part
well I can say there were a lot of
founding fathers I think there's a lot
of Benjamin's here if both Franklin knew
yes now that's too tough no I'm saying
yeah does it really make my point so
this is America
ancient history of America so I'm going
to go 1920
take the colonies
Benjamin Rush our founding father of the
United States yes and if this isn't the
most interesting thing on that man's bio
it is definitely not the most
interesting thing on this man's but was
he in the band Rush
hey no there much later and be no bear
Canadian Benjamin Rush was a physician
was in what a quack and a charlatan uh
he was surprisingly forward thinking for
his time amputations didn't necessarily
do them bad before would thinking ah he
was Surgeon General oh and the
Continental Army Oh in an army okay fine
yes he was authority salute there but
yeah you were right he goes on the due
respect yeah do you respect is what you
give wet grass on the morning I wondered
where you were going with us
oh my god first groaning Surgeon General
mm-hm and innovative inside get away
from operations if he's doing the war
there were some interesting
prescriptions yeah okay Lord know why
painkiller really yes but I don't know
but you believe that well I believe you
it's a got a painkillers another or
antiseptic he gave supplies to a very
famous expedition after the Revolution
now I know your American history is not
great but no bugger all about do the
words Lewis and Clark mean anything to
you
yeah that's not Superman oh but that was
Lois and Clark and that's actually why
they called it that
really oh hang out and Lois and Clark
new adventure speed run was a Lewis and
Clark pond so is this an expedition to
Krypton
it was serving an expedition to
somewhere was it a Westwood one yes well
uh let's not work like a set off and
discover South London
it was a westward expedition what were
they hoping to find the Pacific yes the
Lewis and Clark expedition was trying to
find unsuccessful found a route through
to the Pacific to American territory my
horse and cart not the West would if it
does that don't get behind it until he
stands up for you who actually knows who
Tim Westwood is for about half your guys
that's just lost that exhibition
obviously had a lot of supplies to get
through to get through all the way for
months and months the Pacific and their
doctor was Benjamin Rush shortly for
their initial Nana gave them supplies
what sort of things you give for a
month-long expedition through the
wilderness in 1803 opiates we spot on an
imodium now
I'll get back to you on that but I just
want to point out that yes a Turkish
opium apparent later not only token what
was that for
making sure you have a lovely time oh
you know I'm gonna give you a point
nervousness what to incite it I don't
think we're panicking enough about what
am I going to get there tell me the
opium why aren't all expeditions denied
opiates I hope it run all finds office
techs at the North Pole I gladly watch
that have you read any hunter s Thompson
yeah
the international space station Samar's
on smack do they have a different you
know they rate their expedition by
what's drugs they're using this feels
more like an LSD trip only weighs one
orbit Church opium actually right you
mentioned a fairly obvious joke here
something you give imodium yes did they
have problems of the bomb then meet
Richard diet are and lack of clean water
now getting calls to use coconut other
mallet
accessories rubber mallet that got me
laughs well you're not getting far
enough on your own and you down these
right you don't need the leverage you
don't need wood out you're not sound
soft return on it I would imagine and
you're not going to use Timmy mother
either so that's one for the eighties
kids Italian I thought that was a noise
if he forgot to put the cocking oh they
weren't called imodium they will call it
was per year imodium 50 dozen of dr.
Rush's bilious pill ah I still say those
now this I'm reassuringly comforter come
on I'm off for a billion there also they
also have a sort of weather ish name
something that Mike might call the
rumbling a thunder plunderer oh and I'll
give you the point there was Thunder
clapping oh no anyways brace the
thunderclap is no less what do those
contain because you are B Sena then I
understand like that no I mean bear in
mind um what those you're John as a lady
I used to have everyone necessarily
designed to bring you up
Oh rush believed as you would at the
time in certain theories of medicine
what what merging and things like that
Dumas yes how are you listening little
bit like four humors but it was it was
certainly something bleeding or an Asian
stick a leech on your ass and you've got
to cross me back
oh the poly I'm still inches in upon one
goes on the Kings wound the other one is
going to be home for medical hospital
Ave which we've done plumbing debts very
quickly here I'll be honest nah
it does it does so here even Russia's
den location many physicians had
abandoned on scientific grounds that
remedy
rush just just kind of kept going he
believed in something called heroic
medicine
oh don't want to i where is she going I
want to tell me what what that is I
don't want any kind of doctor with that
kind of heroic mindset thank you very
much but you know might kick my door in
and slam a leech down my throat and go
you are saved and then you know flash as
your doctor
I'm going to syringe Chris office my
back is it basically when when the time
comes you basically say I'm going
outside now I may be some time and they
decide the truth if it's Greek influence
does in narrowing in Greek mythology or
something like that I've learned right
I'm essentially purging vomiting
sweating and blistering so not really
given all that what would you put in dr.
Rush's bilious thunderclap errs anything
to do all those at once oh my god would
you film the clock while that happens we
even this is not something you even want
to touch these days was it poison I mean
the faucet out quickly yes I'll give it
a point but it's an opiate
absolutely spot-on they were 50% mercury
pills well what was the other 50 ah I
[Laughter]
think the correct answer would probably
be if it would be nobs about this chalk
or something like that one day nothing
is gonna kill you
so you talk about more not if you
combine it with mercury you're right
you're right you're right because
chalking flower was a thing and that
would young you're horrible yeah um
there was an interesting side effect for
archeologists much much I mean other
than Oh shining bit I didn't know - I
know look at mercury silver and shiny
isn't it is it horrific ly dangerous to
do archaeological excavations on burial
sites from these people where they died
along the way because their bodies and
skeletons are going to be full of
Quicksilver mercury if you touch with
bare hands it'll seep into your skin and
also give you the even as we
archaeologists call it I set up a man
who looks to all times for living there
sure that certain thing that be careful
with vending has been black black that
you know pestis is very very contagious
cover of like that burial site you have
to really run away
lets you get ill because because a lot
of people got buried in lead coffins I
had of course led the body just corrodes
in it and just
the sludge with the disease persists
within and it is very persistent and
white killed a court of population if it
gets out there are certain play burials
where you just ruin a mile if you think
it's like that so that could happen with
a Quicksilver imbued skeleton Pat not so
stupid now so I like knowing that you
run a mile thus spreading black down for
a mile how do you think it worked in the
first place they were able to trace the
expedition a century or more later
I'm the trail of mercury they left
behind bye-bye then
mercury breadcrumbs yeah yeah what other
reforms as you try and bring my buffing
yeah it could Telegraph but you have to
wire up with and go behind doing that's
pretty much how they lay telegrams yeah
any introduced Hungry Hungry Hippos to
medicine function of Hungry Hungry
Hippos in medicine you will win us the
most pills limit the longest competitive
Wow are they saying is that the modern
Americans even had a mythical fish
stomach entirely Betty stop so you know
who has the most gets the best care yes
satire Oh Oh or was he against
lobotomies I've not actually medicals
also it could have been anyone brothers
family he was also a politician and so
it says here educator soil reformer and
human slavery yes he was he was
anti-slavery ah most promising but
promoter yes yes didn't realize there
was anyone hunt you slavery cut oh yeah
that always been 47 war over it really
didn't one of the one of the arguments
one of the argument of the American
Revolution was do me a favor like a
major royal SAP Maximus
firstly there are actually some
interesting headings here because we
have anti-slavery and then capital
punishment ah when he was also against
they just haven't put the word empty in
the title about one hell of a relative
and the capital footage yeah along with
uncle pillory and cousin swift kick in
the bollocks
you think we're going to kind of buy
laughter they either massively for or
massively against hmm why she bets now
okay thankful babe loudly slavery and
see capital punishment got to be pro
purging so I'm gonna not in like the
movie of the purge centers later because
he brought that in from nowhere pro
burgesses and say he was Pro ladies hey
slick okay here was instrumental to the
founding of the young lady's Academy of
Philadelphia Phillies in village
yeah he proposed genius like the first
charted women's institution of higher
education in Philadelphia what did he
think women should be trained in comfo
um not not exactly driving a steam
engine building wardrobes that thing
will you balance a golf ball on the end
of the golf club then your whole your
top and then hit it yeah I know but Ivan
we can go all day
precision cake Chloe lightly quad sir
not John Berger trick shots we get snoop
evolved into a little wine cooler thing
that they can form Apple Jackie where is
obsessively stressing the rifleman
chanting to himself that it is something
like etiquette for the ladies are not
quite that good housekeeping no you
don't want white on bat okay laughter
there's a line here's armed combat it is
etiquette don't here oh oh nice combat
armor sorry
with the repartee biking and scathing
comebacks that politely so they don't so
the fella doesn't notice this happened
just about two days later wakes up in
the middle in night with a growing sense
of ennui and realizes he missed his
chance forever sorry gossip I got back
in the room Caqueta SH waving of fans to
avoid embarrassment uh morale I say is
poetry and religious writings I'm
history which you know fittingly you
didn't that was Sir Paris tomorrow he's
not delayed what what do you think I
don't know if he escaped your notice but
sir
what do you think women shouldn't be
pushed towards confu precision
Edge's okay and rough uncouth types i
hope is mathematics logic advanced
science in the lives of the room how
many of you would work with us on a
profession
Benjamin Rush is the father of us
children of American some baseball's a
discipline in medicine I guess via bowel
cleavage no it it's nothing rinse do
with with the body as such so a medical
process does not to do with the bit like
blind testing or something like that
actual research I know
research rather than just poking I mean
things to do with a bit of the body but
you would you would say this was this
was not a physical thing to fix these
days this will be something like I
actually mental health alone is
absolutely right but what about the
father of American psychiatry what do
you think was a good way to cure
insanity that's the phrasing they've
used here electroshock treatments no too
early for that oh yeah - exactly I don't
think at this point Benjamin Franklin
had been shocked by the time look at the
size of this kind of playing as arrays
right now a good hard slap to the face I
saw Shore self out not remember what are
you already believed it it was called
caramel I was nice and close to caramel
anime hilarious mixup in a chocolate
factory
it's mercurous chloride so like don't
don't eat coverage calomel how did he
convince his patients who were suffering
from again I'm using the word here
insanity to eat mercury wrapping in ham
rabbit in huh your clothes wrap it in
cheese yeah I'm going to the point
sprinkling a few grains of mercury jelly
on a piece of bread and then spreading a
thin covering of butter over
he believed that mental illnesses were
caused by disruptions of blood
circulation so how might you get some
more blood to the brain did he throw
people in cold water after that
increased circulation uh that would be
slightly more sensible than an
upside-down sleeping like about oil they
call a warming habit your your linked
them like above I go I'm gonna be point
you was a sensory deprivation head
enclosure that we know I on yeah you
think he invented the bucket I just
think it doesn't someone you also had a
more physical way of getting blood to
the brain is it like when you've got an
ice pop and you've got the juice at the
bottom and you want it to the top so you
sort of have to go yeah
we've liked the leg and it's just
forcing the blood up through the body
okay I'm not into a point but you want
right there it was a real tonic aids it
was not quite it was a waste a tectonic
to force blood up to the head is it like
that machine at the end of The Princess
Bride
well you put suction cups on a nice
water-powered going so the sucky life is
just pulls the blood sorry I'm going to
be the point
I've looked on it's not a vacuum or it's
not anything like that but is a spinning
machine someone to much a spin them
around like that and that was how he
thought you cure yes this was in a work
no this was a Miss strike three as
mentioned in the form of a shooting star
engaged yes he actually had a thing
called the moral thermometer the more
blood you have in your brain the better
off you would be so is this like one of
those love testing involved you put your
hand on your hand but you know cold
hands morale top it chilled
you must be hung high I was against the
death penalty
so the well he must be roundly shunned
in a pocket at the end the show
congratulations Gary you in this week
oh yeah you win you win that an express
trip to see the buttock cleavage of one
of nature's deep blacks best practice
crack do you enjoy that with that we'd
say thank you to Chris y'all hi then to
Gary Brannen to my grave Ivan don't got
we'll see you next time thank you folks
you
you